Angular is an open source framework.
Created by Misko Hevery and
is maintained by Google.
But what's so important about Angular?
Why should you even care about it?
Angular is a powerful framework.
That can manage your entire application.
If you don't want all that power though.
You can pick and
choose from Angular's list of features.
It doesn't force you into any
specific file structure or
way to organize your code.
This can be very liberating.
The downside,
though, is that every Angular project
you work on could be different.
So Angular let's you control the app
structure and capabilities.
Keep in mind Uncle Ben's advice.
With great power comes
great responsibility.
Another one of Angular's awesome
features is two way data binding.
Two way data what?
Here's a trimmed down version
of how a template gets its data.
Here's a data object that
gets fed into the template.
This is a very high level overview, but
pay attention to name In
both of these sections.
A typical framework retrieves the data
and displays it in the template.
It's a one way singular
fetch of information.
Angular retrieves its
data in a similar way.
With two way data binding
the information you add, delete, or
change in the browser updates
the underlying data object.
Why don't we take angular for
a spin and see how amazing it is?